>>> WE ARE BACK NOW WITH THE
BREAKING NEWS, TOM BRADY IS
RETIRING AT THE AGE OF 44 AFTER
AN UNBELIEVABLE, ALMOST
UNPARALLELED CAREER.
IT INCLUDED SEVEN SUPER BOWL
TITLES, FIVE SUPER BOWL MVPs,
THREE OVERALL MRPs, AND AS A
44-YEAR-OLD, HE LED THE NFL IN
PASING AND PASSING TOUCHDOWNS
JUST THIS PAST SEASON.
I WANT TO BRING BACK FORMER NFL
WIDE RECEIVER DONTE' STALLWORTH
AND CNN'S COY WIRE WHEN HE WAS
ON DEFENSE WHEN HE WAS IN THE
NFL.
I ASSUME YOU DON'T AGREE ON MUCH
AT ALL OTHER THAN THE
SUPERIORITY OF THE SIDE OF THE
BALL YOU WERE ON.
COY, I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
YOU PLAYED DEFENSE IN THE NFL.
YOU WATCHED TOM BRADY UP CLOSE
AND PERSONAL, PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU WERE WITH THE BILLS WHO I
FEEL LIKE HE TERRORIZED FOR
ROUGHLY TWO DECADES.
WHAT MADE HIM SO DIFFICULT TO
PREPARE FOR AND PLAY AGAINST?
>> GOOD TO TALK WITH YOU AND
DONTE' AS WELL.
I THINK THE BUFFALO BILLS ARE
FINALLY HAVING THE CHANCE OF
BEATING THE PATRIOTS NOW WITH
TOM BRADY NOT THERE ANYMORE,
ALTHOUGH MAC JONES IS PRETTY
GOOD AND BILL BELICHICK IS STILL
THERE.
WHEN I PLAYED FOR THE BUFFALO
BILLS FOR SIX SEASONS, WE PLAYED
AGAINST THOSE PATRIOTS TWICE A
YEAR, EVERY YEAR ONCE HOME AND
ONCE AWAY.
AND IT WAS THE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TASK.
AT LEAST IT SEEMED THAT WAY.
THE ONE TIME WE BEAT THEM IT
FELT LIKE WINNING THE SUPER
BOWL.
IT WAS SO DIFFICULT TO GO UP
AGAINST A TEAM WHERE, YOU KNOW,
FROM A DEFENSIVE STANDPOINT,
IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE TOM
BRADY KNEW OUR DEFENSE BETTER
THAN MOST OF THE GUYS ON OUR
TEAM KNEW OUR OWN DEFENSE.
HE KNEW DEFENSES IN GENERAL.
HE KNOWS HOW TEAMS ARE TRYING TO
ATTACK.
DEFEND, AND HE'S ONE STEP AHEAD
OF THE GAME, AND THAT COMES FROM
PREPARATION, PREPARATION,
PREPARATION.
AND SO THIS IS HIS TB 12 METHOD,
HIS BOOK, WE HEARD ABOUT THIS.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
IT ENCOMPASSES EVERYTHING FROM
HIS MIND-SET AND MENTALITY DOWN
TO HIS DIET AND SLEEPING HABITS.
BEING SUCCESSFUL WAS HIS LIFE.
IT CONSUMED HIM.
IT DROVE HIM.
HE WASN'T THE MOST PHYSICALLY
GIFTED AND PHYSICALLY TALENTED.
THAT'S WHY I CAN RELATE TO
SOMEONE LIKE THAT BECAUSE HE,
YOU KNOW, ADMITTED I WAS NEVER
THE BIGGEST, FASTEST, STRONGEST.
PEOPLE WERE TAKEN AHEAD OF ME,
PICKED AHEAD OF ME IN THE DRAFT
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH, BUT I
WAS GOING TO OUTWORK EVERYONE
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND THAT'S
WHAT HE DID EVERY SINGLE DAY,
AND IT GAVE HIM A CHANCE FOR
SUCCESS.
AND IN DOING SO HE ACHIEVED MUCH
SUCCESS, BUT ALSO IT ELEVATED
THE PLAY OF EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
THAT'S WHY HIS TEAMS, HE CAN GO
TO TAMPA BAY AND INSTANTLY
THEY'RE A SUPER BOWL CONTENDER
BECAUSE HE BRINGS OUT THE BEST
IN EVERYONE BECAUSE IF TOM BRADY
IS DOING ALL THOSE EXTRA LITTLE
THINGS, IF HE'S PAYING ATTENTION
TO DETAIL LIKE THAT, I NEED TO
DO THAT AS WELL.
THAT'S THE GOAT, AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL I'M GOING
TO DO WHATEVER HE'S DOING
BECAUSE IT'S WORKING.
>> I FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY CAN
WATCH HIS NFL COMBINE VIDEO FROM
HOW MANY YEARS AGO AND REALIZE
HE DEFINITELY WASN'T THE MOST
PHYSICALLY TALENTED OR FRANKLY
MOST IN SHAPE, WHICH I THINK
CHANGED OVER THE YEARS.
COY, ONE OF THE THINGS I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE GRASP THE ALMOST
ABSURDITY OF A 44-YEAR-OLD
QUARTERBACK DOING WHAT HE DID,
NOT JUST THIS PAST YEAR BUT OVER
THE LAST FOUR, FIVE YEARS.
AS SOMEBODY WHO PLAYED, CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE PHYSICAL TOLL OF
20 PLUS YEARS IN THE NFL AND
OVERCOMING THAT THE WAY HE DID?
>> YEAH, I PLAYED NINE YEARS, I
HAVE A TITANIUM PLATE, I HAVE
FOUR SCREWS.
I HAVE COUNTLESS OTHER
SURGERIES.
THE GAME IS LIKE RUNNING INTO A
BRICK WALL OVER AND OVER.
IT'S LIKE GETTING IN A CAR
CRASH.
DONTE' CAN ATTEST TO THIS,
PLAYING THE RECEIVER POSITION IN
THE ERA HE PLAYED WHERE THEY
WEREN'T PROTECTING THE PLAYERS
THAT MUCH WITH RULES.
DONTE' WAS OUT THERE GETTING
BLASTED AND TOM BRADY TOOK A LOT
OF HITS OVER THE YEARS, AND WE
HEARD HIM TALK ABOUT THAT
RECENTLY IN THE PODCAST WHERE HE
SPOKE ABOUT IT PAINS HIS WIFE
GISELE TO SEE HIM OUT THERE.
HE WANTS TO ABLE TO THROW THE
FOOTBALL WITH THEM SOMEDAY AND
RUN ROUTES WITH THEM SOMEDAY.
I'M SURE DONTE' WILL ECHO THE
SENTIMENT, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE NOT
ROLLING OUT OF BED AS THE
TYPICAL PERSON OUR AGE WOULD
BECAUSE OF THE TOLL THE GAME
TAKES ON YOU.
THE MENTAL STAMINA AND
PERSEVERANCE H